you have established that you'll do just  pretty much anything in a movie for a  role you once did a total nude scene  completely nude yeah cuz the director  that would be a negotiation for most  guys Roy who immediately said yes I'll  do it  what was marlon wayans as a movie called  a haunted house and Marlon goes hey I  have an idea I go what he goes what if  you're full nude and this scene I'm like  oh yeah alright he goes he'll be funny  trust me I go alright fine so I'm  walking around the set naked and the  crew members are like two on a robe and  I was like now I'm good and they go no  it's not for you we want you to put on a  robe right right right yeah yeah you  don't want to see genitals yeah  you